-Performing "Spud Infinity,"
from their new album,
"Dragon New Warm Mountain
I Believe in You,"
here's Big Thief!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Hey ♪
♪ What's it gonna take ♪
♪ To free ♪
♪ The ce-lestial body ♪
♪♪
♪ From way up there,
it looks so small ♪
♪ From way down here,
♪ One peculiar organism
aren't we all together ♪
♪♪
♪ Everybody steps on ants ♪
♪ Everybody eats the plants ♪
♪ Everybody knows to dance ♪
♪ Even with just one finger ♪
♪ What's it gonna take ♪
♪ To free ♪
♪ The ce-lestial body ♪
♪♪
♪ When I took another look ♪
♪ The past was not
a history book ♪
♪ That was just some
linear perception ♪
♪♪
♪ Ash to ask and dust to dusk ♪
♪ A dime a dozen,
aren't we just ♪
♪ But a dozen dimes will buy
a crust of garlic bread ♪
♪ What's it gonna take ♪
♪ To free ♪
♪ The ce-lestial body ♪
♪♪
♪ When I say celestial ♪
♪ I mean extraterrestrial ♪
♪ I mean accepting the alien ♪
♪ You've rejected
in your own heart ♪
♪ When I say heart,
I mean finish ♪
♪ The last one there
is a potato knish ♪
♪ Baking too long in the sun
of spud infinity ♪
♪♪
♪ When I say infinity,
I mean now ♪
♪ Kiss the one
you are right now ♪
♪ Kiss your body up and down
other than your elbows ♪
♪♪
♪ 'Cause as for your elbows ♪
♪ They're on their own ♪
♪ Wandering like
a rolling stone ♪
♪ Rubbing up against
the edges of experience ♪
♪ What's it gonna take ♪
♪ To free ♪
♪ The ce-lestial body ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]